today's episode of the y-files is
brought to you by established titles
[Music]
here's the nightmare scenario you stop
by your elderly mother's house to check
on her you grab the doorknob it's hot to
the touch you ring the bell and knock no
answer you fish out your key and open
the door you call out but there's only
silence the air is warm there's a sweet
Smoky smell but nothing looks out of
place finally you go into the living
room and you see it in your mom's
favorite chair is a pile of smoldering
Ash completely unrecognizable as human
and just as you convince yourself that
this isn't your mother you see her
jewelry in the gray dust and then the
grizzly sight of your mother's feet
still in their slippers on the floor by
the ashes there was a fire an intense
fire but aside from her chair nothing is
burned even stranger everything in the
house is covered with a thin layer of
pale yellow grease your mother was a
victim of spontaneous human combustion
the rare it happens more often than you
think according to at least one
scientist it could happen to anybody at
any time
even you
in December 2010 in Galway Ireland 76
year old Michael Faraday was found
burned to death the official cause of
death recorded by the coroner was
spontaneous human combustion early that
morning vardy's neighbor was jolted
awake by the sound of an alarm he went
outside and saw smoke coming from
Faraday's house Faraday wouldn't answer
the door when the fire department
arrived Michael Faraday was found
completely incinerated sitting by his
fireplace aside from his chair there was
no other damage to the room or anywhere
in the house investigators couldn't find
any accelerant the coroner referred to
Professor Bernard Knight's book on
Forensic pathology and Dr Knight says
that a high number of incidents of
spontaneous human combustion occur near
an open fireplace or chimney this fire
was thoroughly investigated and I'm left
with a conclusion that this fits into
the category of spontaneous human
combustion for which there is no
adequate explanation on Thanksgiving
weekend 1979 Beatrice ozke said goodbye
to her son Frank Frank didn't realize
that this would be the last time he saw
his mother alive Beatrice had a number
of health problems she was a diabetic
and alcoholic she was also a heavy
smoker the next day Beatrice's
daughter-in-law stopped by and smelt
smoke she called the fire department
when they arrived the scene was all too
familiar Beatrice was reduced to a pile
of Ash but her legs weren't burned she
had shoes on her feet and her left leg
brace was still intact her chair was
burned but nothing else in Beatrice's
house had any sign of fire damage to
cremate a human body you need
temperatures of 2 000 degrees or higher
yet there was a stack of newspapers not
18 inches from Beatrice's chair they
didn't catch fire and like many other
cases of spontaneous human combustion
everything was covered with a thin layer
of oil
the oil come from well it comes from
burning human fat I'm sorry I asked
spontaneous human combustion is not a
recent phenomenon one of the first known
cases happened in Milan in the late 15th
century Italian night polonis vorstias
was a heavy drinker one night after
throwing back a few in front of several
witnesses he started belching fire he
then burst into flames and died another
well-known case happened in the 18th
century in keeper Nicole Malay also a
serious Drinker was the victim of
spontaneous human combustion all that
remained of Malay was her skull a few
bones and her unburned legs all in a
pile of Ash she was found near a straw
bed that somehow didn't catch fire
Nicole malay's husband was actually
convicted of her murder Mr Malay was
later acquitted because there was a
doctor staying in the Inn who saw what
happened Cornelia de Bondi an Italian
Countess died in a similar way she was
found in the morning as a pair of
unburned legs and skull sitting on a
pile of ashes and the room was covered
in soot and grease yep but otherwise
there was no evidence that a fire took
place reports of spontaneous human
combustion continued through the 19th
and 20th centuries in 1938 a 22 year old
woman named Phyllis Newcomb was leaving
a dance at Shire Hall in England when
she suddenly burst into flames she ran
back into the hall and collapsed she
later died in the hospital investigators
could find no evidence of a cigarette or
match or anything that could catch fire
her death was officially ruled
spontaneous human combustion Dr John
Irving Bentley's death was front page
news in 1966 he died in his bathroom all
it was found was his leg and a pile of
Ash people have spontaneously combusted
recently too in 2007 a woman in Brazil
burst into flames in front of several
witnesses her upper body was burned
beyond recognition but her lower body
and even her clothes were undamaged an
investigator said it looked like she
burned from the inside out in 2010
Elizabeth McLaughlin of Ireland and was
found dead in her apartment at first her
cause of death was ruled as smoke
inhalation but a year later her case was
reopened and her cause of death changed
death was caused by fire there was talk
on spontaneous human combustion at the
time I did a little research and that
probably is an urban myth but what I did
see the remains it did come to mind in
2013 Danny Van Zant a 65 year old
alcoholic and heavy smoker was found
completely incinerated in his home aside
from Van Zant's cremated body there is
no other sign of fire Sheriff Ron
Lockhart said I think there's only about
200 cases of spontaneous combustion
worldwide and I'm not saying that this
just happened I'm just saying that we
hadn't ruled it out you could pour
gasoline on somebody and he wouldn't be
as badly incinerated in November 2015 in
flensburg Germany a woman was sitting on
a park bench when according to Witnesses
she suddenly burst into flames in 2016 a
drunk man was asleep in a doorway in a
small town in Serbia people saw white
Flames coming out of his torso a similar
case happened in 1967 when a fireman put
out a fire that was coming from inside a
homeless man's abdomen and the stories
go on and on hundreds of them so what's
going on can we solve this with science
well
in July 1951 Dr Richard Reeser was
visiting his mother Mary Reeser Mary was
depressed that she couldn't travel for
the summer so she told her son that she
was going to take a couple of secondol
tablets and maybe two more before bed
second all is a pretty strong sedative
also called secobarbital also called
Reds Red Devils red dillies right
because of the color of the capsule
Cardinals Red Hots Pink Ladies fannies
Bobs ruby slippers you seem to know a
lot about this yeah what do you want me
to tell you the 80s were wild anyway
around five in the morning Mary's
landlady smelled smoke she went back to
check on Mary and noticed the doorknob
was hot when the landlady and a couple
of neighbors got into the apartment all
that was left of Mary Reeser was a pile
of soot a few pieces of spine a shrunken
skull and one of Mary's undamaged feet
still wearing a slipper shrunken skull
yeah the shrunken skull is extra Strange
Fire investigators will tell you that
they've seen skulls explode because the
brain actually cooks and expands like
putting an egg in the microwave but a
shrunken skull is unusual it's possible
it just looked small in the context of
being in a big pile of Ashes but we see
shrunken skulls appear in other cases
too an investigator said in order for
Mary's body to be so thoroughly cremated
her body would have to burn at 3 000
degrees for three or four hours now this
is much hotter than a fireplace worth
cigarette yet there wasn't a lot of
damage to her apartment and the Damage
that did occur was odd light switches
and electric receptacles that were on
the wall above three feet from the
ground those were melted but switches
lower than that were not candles on a
nearby shelf were melted but their Wicks
stood upright unburned a stack of
newspapers only a few feet away didn't
catch fire the police were stumped the
fire investigators were stumped they
sent some of Mary's remains plus parts
of the chair and other things found at
the scene to the FBI for analysis the
FBI found no trace of anything flammable
not her chair her clothes nothing but
they did find something unexpected in
Mary's rug melted human fat
here's how human combustion Works some
type of chemical reaction takes place
which causes cells to ignite some say
this is a release of enzymes that
drastically increases cell metabolism
and body temperature others say static
electricity builds up inside the body
over time and eventually a spar creates
fire internal fluids are converted into
flammable gas like methane or bacteria
in the gut create a large amount of
methane methane is the accelerant now
you've got fire but to cremate a human
body you've got to burn really hot and
really slowly for hours you need a fuel
source human body fat provides that fuel
remember that in most of these cases an
oily residue is found on everything in
the area that grease is the fat from the
victim's body that's why there was fat
and Mary Reese's rug it melted and
pulled there ahead of these people go up
in the first place well nobody really
knows but there are a few theories Larry
Arnold investigated over 400 cases of
possible spontaneous human combustion
and released a book called Ablaze
according to his research there's a
subatomic particle called a pyroton that
interacts with human cells to create a
microscopic nuclear explosion it appears
in some cases there was what we would
call the human Hiroshima effect that at
the subatomic level in the human body a
chain reaction begins to unleash itself
it radiates outward literally outward
from the subatomic level to the atomic
level to the physical structure of the
human body
and in doing so the tremendous amount of
energy released instantaneously
literally vaporizes the moisture content
of the body away these people become
their own self-immolators their own
crematorium
that guy rocks quite the mullet he does
science in the front body in the back a
new scientist magazine a biologist Brian
J Ford suggested that spontaneous
combustion could be caused by a buildup
of acetone in the body yes what now
acetone nail polish remover is acetone
it's a highly flammable and highly
volatile substance all humans have a
small amount of acetone in their bodies
but this can increase with alcohol
consumption and we do see alcohol
playing a role in a lot of these cases
Brian Ford said diabetes or a specific
kind of diet can cause combustion he
mentioned that cells in ketosis could
become flammable and ketosis is a
metabolic state that happens when the
body is deprived of sucrose this is the
keto diet low carb low sugar hey yeah
didn't you cut out sugar mostly yeah why
but you still drink booze well you gotta
live interesting I don't think I'm
really at risk of
who wants barbecue
[Music]
for a rational explanation of
spontaneous human combustion Skeptics
and most scientists cite the wick effect
in a candle the wick is a piece of
braided fiber usually cotton in the
center of wax wax is a hydrocarbon with
a low melting point and a slow burning
temperature as the wick slowly burns
down wax is melted around the flame and
converted into gas at the same time wax
is pulled up through the wick by a
process called capillarity a candle
burns slowly and evenly and the heat
goes straight up now I don't recommend
putting anything flammable near a candle
like newspaper but if you did as long as
the paper was below the candle flame it
probably wouldn't ignite the wick effect
with human combustion works the same way
although a human is technically an
inside out candle with human combustion
the wick is the victim's clothing as the
body burns fat tissue is melted fat is
also a hydrocarbon so it burns low and
slow and is converted into gas and when
that gas hits walls and objects in the
area which are cooler than the air it
condenses back to solid fat that makes
everything greasy now this has been
tested a few times with pig flesh which
is similar to human flesh as long as a
heat Source can stay connected to
something flammable for long enough to
cause a small fire the wick effect is a
real thing so think of a cigarette which
doesn't burn hot enough to cremate a
human body but Burns hot enough and
slowly enough that it can cause a fire
if a cigarette Falls On A flammable
piece of clothing like a rayon nightgown
for example which is what Mary Reeser
was wearing then you can see how a fire
can start pretty easily most modern
cases of spontaneous human combustion
meaning within the last hundred years
the victims were smokers wouldn't they
know they were on fire well that's where
the alcohol comes in or in Mary reeser's
case a bunch of sleeping pills if
someone is intoxicated or sedated they
might not wake up in time to stop a fire
now considering all these factors we can
create a pretty accurate profile of a
victim of spontaneous human combustion
these people tend to be overweight more
fat means more fuel for the fire they
tend to be elderly and infirmed so stuck
in a chair or in bed which would allow a
large fire to develop from a small one
there's frequently an incapacitating
substance involved like sleeping pills
lots of victims are alcoholics and
finally the victims tend to be heavy
smokers now Mary Reeser wasn't just a
heavy smoker she was an irresponsible
smoker cigarette Burns were found all
over her apartment and in the cases
where cigarettes weren't involved the
victims were near a fire Source like a
fireplace or an oven
feet right a slow burning fire like a
candle or a human is going to burn
straight up so objects below the the
fire Source the victim's torso are going
to be fine so switch is low on the wall
paper is on a coffee table or the
victim's legs won't burn but objects
above the fire Source will be affected
like light switches high on the wall or
plastic picture frames these would melt
and things directly above the heat
Source like the ceiling are always
burned badly the wick effect Theory can
cover most cases of spontaneous human
combustion but not all of them Skeptics
are quick to point out that victims are
always alone without Witnesses but that
that's not always the case in September
1982 Jeannie saffin was sitting in the
kitchen with her father John sappin and
brother-in-law Don Carroll it was the
middle of the day no fire was anywhere
near her out of the corner of his eye
John saw a flash of light he looked at
Genie and she had fire coming out of her
mouth Don Carroll and John saffin said
that the fire was coming from inside her
her clothes weren't burned an ambulance
was called and Jeannie died eight days
later this case was such a mystery that
several police investigators went from
being skeptical of spontaneous human
combustion to Believers and many of
these cases are still open
so can we debunk spontaneous human
combustion nope mostly yes we can at
least the modern cases almost
exclusively so-called spontaneous human
combustion victims are overweight
elderly smokers with mobility issues who
live alone often alcohol or drugs play a
role they drop a cigarette it starts a
small fire and the victim is unable to
move because he or she is too
intoxicated or too immobile or both the
small fire eventually Burns through
their clothing starts to melt away their
fatty tissue and the wick effect takes
it from there tough way to go yeah it is
but in quite a few of these cases the
victim has a heart attack or stroke
while they're smoking and the cigarette
falls into their lap the burning takes
place postmortem every cloud has a
silver lining eh that's one way of
looking at it these fires burn so hot
that all evidence like cigarette butts
are incinerated in a few of the cases
where the victim was a non-smoker they
happened to be sitting near a fireplace
we can assume that a hot Ember jumped
from the fireplace and onto the victim
but some cases are more difficult to
explain in the case of Jeannie saffin
who was supposedly breathing fire there
was no cigarette or fireplace she just
went up even John Hamer a former British
police officer cited the sapin case as
one of the ones that convinced him that
spontaneous human combustion was real
now to be fair to Skeptics the saffron
autopsy revealed that she actually had
no Burns inside her mouth and although
Reports say her clothes were intact and
Genie appeared to burn from the inside
out the official Reports say her clothes
were burned and Genie's burn injuries
were external not internal Nano trust
official reports I know you don't now
there were two fire sources in her
kitchen the pilot light from the stove
that wouldn't do it and her father's
pipe he had just finished smoking and
tapped out his ashes the kitchen window
was open which caused the cross Breeze
burning Ash could have caught that
breeze and landed on Genie who is
wearing a flammable polyester dress we
had lots of wood halves and could halves
in your theory Mr Holmes I know there is
because if you dismiss spontaneous human
combustion as fiction you have to work
with the facts that you have no matter
how much of a stretch now there are
plenty of people who believe in
spontaneous human combustion scientists
police officers even fire investigators
they all say the same thing they never
believed in the phenomenon until they
ran across a case or multiple cases that
couldn't be explained then they changed
from skeptic to believer Occam's razor
says the simplest answer is usually the
correct one I believe that the vast
majority of spontaneous human combustion
cases can be explained elderly smokers
living alone with mobility issues who
have a fondness for drink now they're at
risk from all sorts to things not least
of which dying in a tragic Accidental
Fire the simplest answer is usually the
correct one but not always sometimes the
correct answer is not so simple
sometimes the answer is so difficult
that it's completely beyond our
understanding if spontaneous human
combustion is real there's probably not
much we can do to protect ourselves and
avoid it but if you're an overweight
elderly smoker enjoying a martini by the
fire wear nice shoes because at some
point that might be all that's left of
you
[Music]
foreign
is brought to you by one of the most
unique sponsors we've ever had
established titles and that doesn't
sound like VPN software it's not huh
nice change of pace established titles
let you buy as little as one square foot
of land in Scotland and this allows you
to call yourself Lord or Laird as they
say or lady also established titles
plants a tree with every order and is
partnered with great Charities like one
tree planted
hold on what did you just say I could
buy land in Scotland and become a lord
yep you can even use the title on your
credit cards plane tickets online dating
profile yep so I want it well there's
more I want to tell you about this I
want it now
Heckle fish Comanche fine
[Music]
package
you're kidding me right
what is this
um what is this my Lord if you don't
mind yeah you might be taking this a
little bit
okay okay hang on I could get used to
this
okay this certifies you as Lord
hecklefish Moriarty and uh this is the
plot Number of your land in Edelson
Scotland and uh they even sent us
coordinates Google Map [__]
it is I can't wait to get some Surf Shop
there to work the land for me and pay me
tribute uh you you can't have any serves
I shall be a strict Fair law
s me you can't have serfs I could maybe
have a few safes you can't one surf no
stop saying surfs stop saying surfs my
Lord all right but check this out the
first 200 people who purchased a title
pack using the promo code twf will get
land right near yours
yeah I'll be a strict but fair Lord to
all who purchase using promo code twf
well you won't be there Lord there'll be
Lords and Ladies of their own land but
for now but when I raise an Army in
coconut land I shall rule over them and
they will come to know me as a strict
but fair Lord you can't conquer their
land they may be a marriage pact to
strengthen the kingdom I don't see how
that shall be truth my eldest son to the
daughter of one of the other Lords we
will unite our kingdoms and my blood
shall rule these lands for a thousand
years you have an eldest son what do you
think those guppy support payments are
for Heckle Jr lives with his mother in
Hackensack New Jersey if you use code
twf you'll get an additional 10 off so
go to establishtitles.com twf you'll be
Lord of your own land you'll get your
own plot number and you get this cool
frame certificate this makes an amazing
last minute gift plus you'll be
supporting a great charity and helping
out the channel and you'll be joining my
kingdom right and that you will come to
know me as a
it don't make me declare premenacta ugh
gross
[Laughter]
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that's hecklefish
this has been the white files if you had
fun or learned anything do me a favor
and like subscribe comment share I know
it's annoying but it really helps the
channel and like most topics we cover on
this channel today's topic was
recommended by you and if there's a
story that you'd like to see or learn
more about go to thewifiles.com tips and
special thanks to our patrons who make
this channel possible I'm amazed by your
generosity and if you'd like to support
the channel consider becoming a member
on patreon or grabbing something from
the white file store that's gonna do it
until next time be safe be kind and know
that you are appreciated
[Music]
thank you